what does like your process look like
from idea to video being published and
like what are the steps along the way
what are the who are the people that
sort of get involved with making an idea
come to life yeah so let's go with uh
let's go with a classic video reviewing
a phone right
so step one is the phone arrives at the
studio and i take it out the box
sometimes i'll shoot the unboxing if i
know that's gonna be part of the video
and i put my sim card in it i set it up
and i start using it and i start testing
it i actually mentioned i forgot one of
them earlier writer researcher script
supervisor david will help me with a lot
of the research and making sure we've
got all the points worth mentioning
about this device about this phone all
in one doc so i'm taking notes as i'm
using it we're
brain dumping into this document and
then eventually we get to the point
where we're like all right i think we've
got it i think we've got everything
let's turn it into
a script a story a through line
something that's worth watching
that's basically my job is to
to translate all of this information
into
the headline the thumbnail the thing
that will live on youtube
then we shoot the thing so
there's sort of two versions i'm sure
you do this too there's a role in b-roll
so you shoot your a-roll where you're
talking to the camera and then you have
pieces where you know you're gonna be
you know you're talking but you also
have like footage ready for when you're
gonna talk about that stuff we typically
start with shooting a-roll so that i
have all of the talking out of the way
and then we know all the little quirks
and things that i've mentioned and then
we will go shoot all of the rest of the
b-roll to cover all the things we need a
lot of that is ben and brandon shooting
b-roll off on their own a lot of that is
i've got a couple shots in mind i need
i'll i'll grab them and go up to the
roof and we'll go shoot some stuff that
i know we need to get
we cover the whole script everyone has
access to the script then it gets edited
for the most part that's just me
ingesting all the footage and laying it
down on the timeline and then if there
is any sort of extra fancy visuals
then we'll go sort of next level say
this one as a robot shot in the intro
i'll be editing the main video while
andrew vin and brandon will go off to
the robot studio and will make their
incredible masterpiece and then that can
tie in back to what i've been editing so
they'll give me a couple ideas we'll
pick one we'll go this is one that would
really work with the youtube tagline and
sort of you can see the whirlwind
happening as the content gets made it
gets to the end of the process i finish
the video we give it one last walk
through the whole timeline watch the
whole video together any last
adjustments okay it's good export upload
publish hey friends thank you so much
for watching if you enjoyed this clip
then click here for the full unedited
episode and if you like that then do
please consider subscribing to the
channel it means a lot thank you so much
and have a great day